GAME  SCHULTZ WITH A
QUICK THAT PART OF
THE GAME.
>> Brendan: IRWIN IN HIS FIRST
SEASON WITH THETHAT'S A GOOD
ICE.
>> Brendan: PAGEAU BACK IN THE
LINEUP FOR THE
TO WILLSON.
WITH IT.
ISLANDERS GET MIXED UP IN THEIR
COVERAGE.
AFTERNOON.F HIS NHL  BODY
THEY'VE GOT A BACK-TO-BACK.
THEY'RE HEADED HOME TO TAKE ON
THE V V LEFT ARM OF VARLAMOV,
WAS SQUARE OFF THE MIDDLE OF TH
NOW HE'S BY THE NET AND GETS
THAT STICK UP INTO THE HAND
AREA.
A GOOD CAL KUZNETSOV.
>> Butch: INTERESTING WAY TO
KILLRE IS TREVOR VAN
RIEMSDYK COMING INTO PLAY.
AND REALLY DIDN'T HAVE MUCH
OPPORTUNITY TO BE SET.
RECOGNIZED WHAT WAS GOING  SCOR.
>> Brendan: CARLSON FROM THE
LINE.
THAT KNUCKLED AFTER CHANGING BE.
NICE MOVE BE DOBSON TURNED 22 L.
SECOND PERIOD THINGS THEY
STRUGGLE WITH AT TIMES -- IS
GE WITH A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY.
THERE'S THE
KUZNETSOV.
DOBSON FOR THE WALL.
ISLANDERS AGAIN WITH IT.
>> Butch: HUNG ON TO IT.
THEN HE LOOKED TO GET IT BACK U.
NELSON WITH A AFINALLY, AS S
THEY HAVE TO KEEP IT GOGO MIDSE?
NO ROOM TO GET THE PUCK UP IN
THE AIR.
ANY WAY, SHAPE,
McMICHAEL.
ELLER OFFWAHLSTROM.
WILSON WRAPS THE BOARDS.
IRWIN TRYING TO KEEP IT IN.
HE DID.
JUST
HIM.
HERE'S PELECH TO THE SLOT.
PARISE FIGHTING THROUGH.
A LOT OF GUYS LET THAT GO
THROUGH THE NOW.
>> Brendan: PUCK BATTLED FOR.
NELSON HELPED
FROM THE HASH BOARDS -- OR
THERE'S HATHAWAY WITH THE
SA